[Music]  Selena Gomez soaking up the Sun down  under check out the pop star enjoying  the vacation life during her trip to  Sydney Australia on Monday Selena was  spotted out at sea with her pals aboard  a luxury yacht flashing her toned abs in  a orange bikini top and black bottoms  she looks serene and carefree while  reading and tanning on the deck of the  boat and cell had an avocado on hand for  a quick midday snack I like to choose to  live my life in a way where I want to be  wait frames last week a source told ET  Selena has been overwhelmed by the  public nature of her rekindled romance  with Justin Bieber quote Selena is very  delicate her comeback to the spotlight  has been tough especially with the  interest in her personal life with  Justin she is taking time to herself  this might explain why the Biebs was  nowhere in sight during cells getaway  instead Justin spent the weekend in LA  I'm having a good time  [Music]  [Applause]